Fall is fast approaching, and you know what
that means: cooler weather, back to school
sales, and an updated Netflix lineup to keep
you indoors and away from it all.
September's heralding a galaxy's worth of
new programming for the streaming service.
On the Netflix originals side, we're looking
forward to new seasons of Bojack Horseman
and Narcos, plus a handful of Netflix original
movies.
And an end-of-summer binge wouldn't be complete
without the upcoming true-crime satire American
Vandal.
Here's an in-depth look at everything coming
to Netflix in September 2017.
Narcos Season 3
The DEA is setting its sights on a new drug
lord in the third season of its addicting
crime drama Narcos.
Where the first two seasons fixated on Colombian
kingpin Pablo Escobar, the newest season will
raise the stakes even higher as the DEA launches
its operation against the Cali Cartel.
Pedro Pascal returns as DEA agent Javier Pena,
delivering more of the same gripping, real-life
drama that catapulted the first two seasons
to critical acclaim.
Get ready to binge September 1.
Little Evil
Call us crazy, but Little Evil looks like
it just may be one of the best movies of 2017.
Starring Adam Scott and Evangeline Lilly,
and written and directed by Tucker and Dale
vs Evil's Eli Craig, Little Evil is a horror
comedy about a newly married man who may just
be the new stepdad to the antichrist.
Get set for big, dark laughs when Little Evil
hits on September 1.
Resurface
With gorgeous visuals and a heartfelt message
about veterans struggling to find their place
in the world, Resurface documents the journey
of a suicidal ex-soldier who uses surfing
as a way to escape his physical and emotional
pain.
Along the way, he finds a community of like-minded
veterans searching for peace among the waves.
Experience the journey September 1.
Marc Maron: Too Real
Comedian Marc Maron has been making the world
laugh for years with his WTF podcast, and
he's recently experienced a resurgence on
Netflix thanks to his role on Glow.
Now, he's dishing out laughs with a brand
new stand-up comedy special, Too Real.
Look for it September 5.
Bojack Horseman : Season 4
Bojack's back, and this time it's serious.
Sometimes.
Other times, it's bound to be funny, heartwarming,
tear-jerking, and poignant.
Maybe a bunch of those all at once, because
you never know what you're going to pull out
of that bag.
Netflix has been pretty quiet about the details
for the fourth season of Bojack Horseman,
so we'll just have to wait for Bojack's return
on September 8.
#REALITYHIGH
Nobody likes meeting their partner's ex, but
things get extra hairy when that ex happens
to be a social media starlet who's out for
your blood.
#REALITYHIGH is a Netflix original comedy
starring Kate Walsh, Anne Winters, and John
Michael Higgins.
It premieres September 8.
Greenhouse Academy: Season 1
Following two siblings at a boarding school
in California who find themselves in the middle
of a mystery, Greenhouse Academy stars Heartland's
Jessica Amlee and newcomer Finn Roberts.
Check out the first season on September 8.
The Confession Tapes: Season 1
The first season of Netflix's documentary
series The Confession Tapes drops September
8, focusing on convicted murderers who claim
to be innocent.
If The Confession Tapes is received half as
well as Making a Murderer, it may be destined
to become a new true crime classic.
Fire Chasers: Season 1
What if your day job put you at risk of being
engulfed in flames on a regular basis?
From the producers of Deadliest Catch, Fire
Chasers follows the firefighters who go face-to-face
with California's deadly wildfires to protect
the people in the fire's path.
Check it out on September 8.
Jeff Dunham: Relative Disaster
Taped at a live show in Ireland, Relative
Disaster is chock full of Jeff Dunham's trademark
mash-up of humor and ventriloquism.
Get ready for all-new jokes, all-new hijinks,
and, of course, all-new puppets on September
12.
Strong Island
On September 15, Netflix is adding to their
docu-drama selection with Strong Island, a
powerful look into murder and racism on Long
Island during the early '90s.
Diving into the real-life story of a young
African-American who was murdered, and the
justice system that failed his family, Strong
Island isn't for the faint-hearted.
Strong Island is one of the most intimately
moving portraits of racism in recent memory.
Strap in, because these are stormy seas.
And on the other end of the spectrum, we have...
American Vandal: Season 1
The trailer for Netflix's American Vandal
plays this story of mystery and true crime
hilariously straight despite its simple premise:
Someone at Hanover High School, someone nefarious,
defaced the school with a ton of hand-drawn
dongs.
It's the biggest mystery on campus — who
doodled the doodles?
Will the mystery vandal ever be brought to
justice?
And more importantly, will the wrong man pay
the price for the peters?
Find out on September 15.
First They Killed My Father
Directed by Angelina Jolie, First They Killed
My Father is a historical docu-drama set during
the time of the Khmer Rouge regime in Cambodia.
The story is told from the perspective of
a five-year-old girl struggling to survive
the harsh regime, promising a gripping, heartfelt
tale of courage and the strength of the human
spirit.
First They Killed My Father premieres September
15.
Jerry Before Seinfeld
You don't become the world's highest paid
comedian by sitting back and resting on your
fame, and Jerry Seinfeld is back in the saddle
with a brand new stand-up special.
The first release in Seinfeld's $100 million,
two-special deal with Netflix, Jerry Before
Seinfeld is, as the name suggests, all about
the early years in Seinfeld's career, before
the hit show, and before the fame.
Check it out when it hits Netflix on September
19.
Fuller House: Season 3
Way back on September 22, 1987, the first
episode of Full House premiered on ABC and
introduced the world to the Tanner family.
Now, the third season of the popular Netflix
sequel series, Fuller House, is premiering
exactly 30 years later, as revealed by actress
Candace Cameron Bure in an Instagram post.
Only the first nine episodes are premiering
on Netflix on September 22, while the second
half of the season will likely hit in late
2017 or early 2018.
Jack Whitehall: Travels with My Father
You may know Jack Whitehall from his stand-up
comedy or from the comedy series Fresh Meat.
The British comedian joins the Netflix roster
this month with Travels with My Father.
The series follows Whitehall and his dad as
they travel around Europe and try to bond
— which goes about as well as you'd expect
with a goofball and a grumpy old man.
"A priest would not say you're such a little
s---, he'd probably forgive me"
"He'd probably tell you to f--- off."
Look for it on September 22.
Terrace House: Aloha State: Part 4
If you haven't seen Netflix's original reality
series Terrace House, it's definitely worth
a watch.
In the vein of reality mainstays like The
Real World, the show throws a group of strangers
into a house together and turns on the cameras.
While the previous seasons took place in Japan,
Aloha State moves the action to sunny Hawaii.
Dig in for Part 4 on September 26.
Gerald's Game
Adapted from the Stephen King novel of the
same name, Gerald's Game stars Carla Gugino
and Bruce Greenwood as Jessie and Gerald,
a husband and wife whose vacation soon takes
a turn for the worse.
Gerald's Game is directed by Mike Flanagan,
who's already garnered some serious street
cred in the horror genre with his previous
films like Hush and Oculus.
Check it out on September 29.
Our Souls at Night
Robert Redford and Jane Fonda star in Our
Souls at Night as two elderly neighbors who
form an unexpected bond years after their
spouses have died.
The film is based on a novel by Kent Haruf,
and the story it tells is a poignant glimpse
of love and loss.
Queue it up on September 29, and keep a tissue
handy.
Big Mouth: Season 1
Netflix calls Big Mouth "a 10-episode, half-hour
edgy adult animated comedy from real-life
best friends Nick Kroll and Andrew Goldberg
about the glorious nightmare that is teenaged
puberty."
If the pre-release clips are any indication,
it'll definitely be an odd show, but it has
plenty of comedy heavyweights behind it.
Other voice actors tied to the show include
Maya Rudolph, Jordan Peele, Fred Armisen,
and Jenny Slate.
Big Mouth premieres on September 29.
Club de Cuervos : Season 3
This comedy series marked Netflix's first
Spanish original show when the streaming service
released the first season in 2015, and it
turned out to be a pretty good move.
With an 80% rating on Rotten Tomatoes, the
first two seasons were quick to pull in fans.
And now would be a good time to go rewatch
those seasons, because the third one is dropping
on September 29.
The Magic School Bus Rides Again: Season 1
Who could forget The Magic School Bus, the
classic '90s show that entertained and educated?
Well, hold onto your inner child, because
The Magic School Bus is getting a reboot.
According to Netflix, the new show will follow
Miss Frizzle's sister, and is slated for a
September 29 release.
New Movies
Netflix is kicking off the month with a ton
of new movies along with a handful of old
favorites.
Highlights include the criminally underrated
Brazilian crime drama City of God, Martin
Scorsese's hard-hitting epic Gangs of New
York, and Quentin Tarantino's stylish Pulp
Fiction, all of which drop on September 1.
For new releases, keep an eye out for the
upcoming 2017 sci-fi action thriller Alien
Arrival, about a soldier marooned on an alien
moon.
Look for it September 23.
And you better believe you'll be able to get
your shark fix this month, with the entire
Jaws franchise and Deep Blue Sea also hitting
Netflix on the first of the month.
It's the perfect time for a movie marathon...if
the sharks will let you.
And if you want some good jokes, Netflix is
loading up with All Star Comedy Jam stand-up
specials on September 1.
If stand-up's not your thing, tune into Absolutely
Anything, starring Simon Pegg and featuring
the voices of Robin Williams and members of
the Monty Python crew, on September 27.
New documentary releases include Facing Darkness,
coming September 5, and Ghost of the Mountains,
available for streaming on September 13.
And if you love music, you can't miss out
on George Harrison: Living in the Material
World, an in-depth look into the life and
music of the former Beatle, directed by Martin
Scorsese.
Look for that on September 15.
Finally, what's cooler weather without a cozy
family movie night?
Pop some popcorn and settle in with the kids,
because Netflix is boosting their Disney selection
this September with the addition of Mulan
and Hercules on the 1st, Pocahontas on the
14th, and Beauty and the Beast on the 19th.
New Television
Bingeing on your favorite shows will be easier
than ever this month, with a new season of
The Blacklist hitting on September 7, The
Walking Dead on the 8th, Gotham on the 21st,
and Dark Matter on the 25th of the month..
And keep an eye out for Final Fantasy XIV:
Daddy of Light, a quirky Japanese series which
chronicles a father and son bonding over — you
guessed it — Final Fantasy.
Now that's an intriguing premise.
For the international crowd, Netflix is bringing
on Star Trek: Discovery, the first Star Trek
show since Star Trek: Enterprise wrapped back
in 2005.
Discovery follows the crew of a new ship called
the Discovery, and it's set about 10 years
before the events of The Original Series.
Set your phasers to fun on September 25.
Well, everywhere except the US and Canada,
that is.
"Most illogical."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!